so dude read you it's one thing
directing actors but when you're
directing an action star like Freddie
Wong
it's a little bit nerve-racking man I
don't know what to expect
Freddie Wong dude this guy's a pledge
real very liberating yeah oh yes I know
I'm the only one wearing shorts on this
Angeles day I found a bug in Windows and
I did a little bit of searching online
and it's been there for months it's such
a dumb thing see undo undoes the
creation of that folder and the thing is
anything's inside that folder disappear
I was working on an art project last
night I was doing some work on Photoshop
and I lost two hours of work just dumb
bug who the nice little bug baton all
that all your files without even
touching a delete button hmm let's say
you're gonna sit down and work out a
project and you create a folder for your
project called my project it was my
project cool
who'd have thought that the guy who
invented Photoshop would one day write a
Star Wars movie okay really yeah no I
didn't know he wrote yeah that's right
that's crazy anyways I'm working hard on
this amazing work of art right hours and
hours every pixel in the perfect spot
every line the stroke of genius this
this moves me and it's going to move
millions of people good times right
here's all my masterpieces let's say I'm
going to come in a zip file he would
actually happen last night that all my
photoshop files ready and it's gonna
send them off and knope's I made that I
made a zip file one file set of all
three files so hit him dude wait okay
all right so where's my folder now
wait we're not my masterpieces go wait
hi I'm a goon
just feel like now that not enough
people know what it's like to be a goon
I just really want to get our story out
there you always hear about the top dog
the kingpin but like us goons don't
really get the recognition we deserve
and we've always we've always been
around you know goons have been around
for as long as the the real bad guys and
we're working for the bad guy I guess
we're not bad guys I just want people to
see that we're people just like anybody
else we're people with families and
passions and hobbies
we're just goons we all took these jobs
because we needed the money because
nobody grows up wanting to be a goon
obviously I mean it wasn't until last
week that I just realized we were the
bad guys
for this corridor video me and Jake and
Brett we got all dressed up at the goon
Factory over there
mix and match create your own goon
personality I've got my goon goggles and
a little goon hat I'm more of like a
fix-it goon I'm gonna come in I might
wacky over hit a head with a wrench but
really I'm just here to fix the cars
Brett he just went in there they're
shooting with him now she was going up
there somewhere I hope he comes back
being a goon is kind of dangerous
sometimes you never really know if
you're gonna make it out alive
camera speeds and I just I mean I made
my new folder
I made my screen my artistic works saved
my artistic works in that new folder I'm
just make mobile files to drive a point
home so after I've made my files I want
to make a sip of them so I select them
all and try to make a sip
Lily made as if with like one file where
I'd made a mistake and I'd sift 1 files
involved so I went to undo the creation
of zip do the zip it did the whole
folder it's not an inhibitor but it
deleted all my work without any warning
and I couldn't get it back
so truth be told I've never fired a gun
before but strength in numbers there's
three of us goons I don't know how many
guys they got out there you never tell
us that yeah they never do
we don't really ever know what we're
running into either I've from what I've
heard it seems like we just run into the
room and just have to immediately assess
the situation you're ready for my
favorite memory of goon in this is
returning home every night to my my wife
and children I think we'll be fine
we're gonna kill it my favorite memory
of Coonan is returning home every night
to my my wife and children
we just got to paint black a way to do
this slam right just get close right
here just just four years I'll do it a
to be ready to go okay so start to start
here it's right here what it's a beep
hello I'm Gemma's Allender today i am
playing Rebecca
she is the damsel in distress
she toyed with him someone's gonna come
rescue her how do you think he's done
thing Adrienne's done pretty good got a
lot of a lot of very weird stuff a stuff
that's looking consistently well lit
that's the first thing that usually goes
when when things get hectic and things
get rushed the first thing that look at
you this is in this stability of your
camera and you'll lose lighting it gets
a little bit haphazard but he's managed
to keep that discipline which is good as
well dust it a lot of baby powder is I
know it's a good shoot is when you're
sticky you're covered in powder you've
been crying although everything inside
the folder just because you fat fingered
control-z which is not the delete button
I know people say well you shouldn't do
if you want to do it's like undo is not
delete and currently I'm windows anytime
you delete something or given a warrant
but this in this case it just Boop gone
there's a moment last night when I say
that I was like okay where's that folder
now wait where that folder go oh no oh
no see that's another thing you could be
in Photoshop and you've actually
selected your explored you hit undo to
like I'm do something you just didn't
Photoshop and you undo all your work and
this is just the problem sitting in
Windows and I guess I don't know is this
the first time they're hearing of it
maybe you guys can send this video to
Microsoft and Dec hey I'm just letting
you know if you undo and explore you can
delete all the files in a folder without
any sort of warning we could
accidentally undo like we could be to
pull the footage folder dump all our
footage from the date that folder you
guys oh I I named that folder amor
zip or it could be think you're in
premier when you're still on the
Explorer and hit ctrl Z and then all
your footage just disappears so
Microsoft please fix a [ __ ] so we're
gonna do its dude ready and I'm gonna
slide all the way down okay to back up a
little bit
so dude actually this is like I guess is
how I do it just buy a bunch of bottles
of Tears and like just Luis does it yeah
Visine sponsors down
[Music]
sorry we were we were talking about
historically have I ever shown up in the
corridor vid video I think this is
actually the first short which I which
is crazy because Twitter I want the god
I love the collabos but I'm like I was
in a snapper hero and I put Sam deco in
being in high school season 2 so like
the longer form things I don't think
we've ever done on court video have I I
don't think so my god we were going
through the list I was like I don't
think I've been something that quarter
you'll have to always just use D give
you a boy F wanna call every soften you
know we'll see how this video turns out
first you're not gonna get to finish
this video today